[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
the host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to midsummer from RE aster is due
to release in less than a month and
after the film received its first
screening last night I thought I'd go
and check out the movie script which was
leaked online to break down everything
you need to know about the film
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the big plot points of it as well as
giving my take on the movie and what we
will see in it this is full spoilers
ahead and whilst leaks like this should
always be taken with a grain of salt the
script seems fully fleshed out and is
reportedly what was shot after reading
it all lines up so I think this will be
the final cut so if you don't want
anything rude then I highly suggest that
you turn off now because we're going
into every aspect of the plot including
the movies ending without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of bit simmer the film opens
with Danny played by Florence Pugh
receiving a worrying email from her
sister who has a long history of doing
impulsive things due to bipolar disorder
the email reads icon anymore
everything's black mum and dad are
coming to goodbye this mysterious
alarming contact sets off a chain of
events that leads to terrifying
consequences for Danny and those around
her and while it doesn't really tie into
the later plot it's still a great way to
start the story early on the stakes rise
quite a bit when Danny's sister Terry is
found in her parents house after having
apparently killed them and herself and
this loss of family becomes one of the
main reasons that she's drawn to the
cult in the film Danny and Christian her
boyfriend were having relationship
difficulties and the latter plan to
break things off - - the two wanting
different things from life however
Danny's family's death caused him to
stay with her for six months on from the
murders which is when the majority of
the movie takes place Christian wants to
get away to acquire yodelling festival
that only happens once every 90 years in
Sweden known as housing
and this has been organized by their
friend pal who is from the area and is
left due to a pilgrimage that all the
villages take once they reach a soon age
Christian originally was planning on
going with just his friends and - Danny
but after she killed trips him he allows
her to come much to his friends dismay
Danny feels distant from Christians
friends and she has several breakdowns
every time her family's brought up by
them this seems to be a regular thing
and they're constantly reminding her of
the tragedy things slowly gets stranger
and stranger as the group arrive and
discover the cult Appel is originally
from these guys are basically the
product of generations of incest that
hang boar Caucasus from branches and
look like 19th century farmers that
spend most of their time dancing around
the Maypole on the surface they seem
like above hippies that Hanna magic
mushrooms like it's nothing however as
they begin to carry out their rituals
it's clear that things aren't right they
far outnumber the group and this makes
them intimidating as they slowly start
to pick everyone apart the whole gasp as
they're known communicate through little
gestures and expressions known as
effects which hint has their true
intentions without notifying others they
represent nature's hermaphroditism and
because of this the men wear long
dresses and so on every time one Hagen
is born the group plant a tree that has
apparently tied directly to their life
and as it grows they do - if something
happens to that tree they view it as an
attack on themselves and this plays into
the film later the whole gasps view
their lives as seasons with spring being
their childhood and summer their young
adulthood in which they go on a
pilgrimage they return after 32 to be an
elder of the camper autumn and commit
suicide when turning 72 by jumping off a
cliff though we don't discover this back
to lay yet in the film it's not just the
villages that are weird though in
general there's something very wrong
with the place such as a broad daylight
at night and weird things happen to the
area that the group find difficult to
tell apart the reality of they begin
their ceremony to celebrate the
midsummer a ritual at last 9 days and is
headed up by the group's matriarch known
as
unfortunately the ritual which is sort
of like a Groundhog Day thing predicts
bad omens and after this the group
slowly begin to unearth the ins and outs
of the camp this includes strange films
that sent a heavily around pregnancy and
the suicide commit by the eldest there's
a lot more than this and those are just
the main ones but in them they cover
goddesses rebirth worshiping the Sun and
so on Christian also states that he
wants to write his thesis on the Hargis
which annoys Josh who has the same idea
now this is about the midpoint of the
script and things slowly ramp up until
Danny wants to leave due to all the
strange pagan worship that's going on
however Christian convinces her
otherwise to to his project and she
stays though as we make it through the
latter part of the story it becomes
clear that she wouldn't have been
allowed to leave even if she'd wanted to
this is cemented by two friends on the
trip named simon and connie who want to
go after witnessing a mass animal
sacrifice whilst connie is packing
father art comes to tell her that simon
has already left but something seems
well odd about it especially when connie
witnesses him being dragged into the
woods everyone is slowly turning against
them especially after mark breaks a tree
tied to one of the villages named earth
and his life the group also at this
point learn about ruben massively
disabled boy he was seen as the town's
oracle they failed to find simon and
josh sneaks into their sacred temple to
take photos of their sacred texts for
his project known as the ruby radar it's
at this point that mark seemingly walks
in the temple to see him however it's
elf wearing mark skin and yeah it's
about to get a little crazy
josh is bludgeoned and the other members
are put in weird situations Danny is
drugged and made to dance around the
Maypole with others who are all dancing
till they collapse so that one can be
crowned the queen Christian is told that
he has been approved to mate with one of
the doors of the Hargis which makes him
go back and forth on whether he should
cheat an art as he's promised that Danny
will never know and overall it's clear
the camp woman it
letting them the girl he's been chosen
for has been flirting with him since
their arrival and she's described in the
script is very attractive
Danny wins the competition and is
pronounced them a queen and she paraded
through the field unable to really fight
back as people kiss her and adorn her
with flowers
she's eventually led to the throne at
the head of the table where they force
her to eat a salt herring and she
hallucinates through the majority of it
with flowers seemingly growing out of
her feet and a body blending into things
like a chameleon Christian too is really
tripping and the elders clap in his face
which sends him into a downward spiral
at this point Danny is sent out to bless
the crops and Christian is sent to make
love to Maya the girl that the elders
have approved he mates with he's pretty
much stoned throughout and it's one of
the weirdest sex scenes I've ever read
with old naked people standing around
and smiling at him as he does it one of
them also rocks his hips back and forth
and yeah it's just it's pretty weird
Christian finishes and maha begins to
rock back and forth on her saying I can
feel it his life inside me and yep one
star on TripAdvisor for this place
Danny discovers this and begins crying
and breaking down and mimicking her the
other villages start to in an almost
tribal way which is when Christian
rushes out vomits and then sees Josh
chained to a fence with his abdomen cut
open and covered in bird seed so that
they would fly in and peck at his organs
to make things worse josh is still alive
and Christian slowly discovers the rest
of the camp all murdered in brutal ways
he's knocked out and awakens to find
himself in a field the next day ready to
be sacrificed to the Sun and tell all
there are nine sacrifices with a handful
of villages stepping forward and the
ninth being decided by the May Queen she
of course chooses Christian and all of
the corpses and living people are
escorted to a house that was previously
off-limits when it's stacked against the
walls Christian is put in a bear costume
and the room laden with hay is set
alight
he watches Christian melts into the fire
and Danny is paraded as the new queen
she goes through a mix of emotions
including excitement fear confusion but
ultimately she's happy happy that she
finally has a new family and is accepted
the character has gone insane but in her
mind she is a queen worshipped by all
and finally living a life free of
paranoia a distrust which ends the film
so obviously there's quite a lot of
things to take from this and whilst the
script is pretty great when reading it I
always had a nickel in feeling that this
will play out a lot better on the big
screen though I didn't go massively into
detail the description of the location
in Sweden as well as some of the deaths
are really vivid it's really got me
amped up to see how they play out in the
final cut this definitely has the
potential to be the most unnerving movie
of the air and if it follows in the
footsteps of hereditary which is my film
of 2018 then we definitely have a lot to
look forward to obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the film and I'll
leave a link to the script in the
description if you'd like to read it
yourself it's only a 118 pages long and
it's a breeze to read through so I
definitely recommend that you check it
out if this videos piqued your interest
if you enjoyed this then make sure you
check out my breakdown of the leaked
information we have on the Batman which
would be linked at the end it contains
all of the latest news and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to learn more about the Matt Reeves
film so make sure you give that watch
after this this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]